in this portion of our world views and
values class we're now going to turn to
two works by a very important 19th
century German philosopher Karl Marx now
Marx is better known for his his work in
economics and political theory in
sociology then he is as a philosopher to
many people and to those who might be a
little off put at having to study Marx
we're looking at two documents that are
relatively early in his career and we're
looking at them in a philosophical way
we want to understand how he fits in to
some of the key themes that we've been
looking at the entire term namely the
understanding of human nature of society
and of the underlying reality that
encompasses both of those so Marx has a
lot to say about those in these works
and as usual what we want to keep in
mind as we're approaching them are the
three key elements of genre what kind of
work we're dealing with historical
context and then the main themes all of
these inter penetrate each other and
influence each other so we're going to
treat each one of these in turn we're
looking at two different works here
although they're overlapping in content
to some degree so we really have two
different genres at work now one of the
works translated as a stranger alienated
labor is actually a set of notes the
other work the Communist Manifesto is
exactly what it says a manifesto so
let's think about these two different
kinds of genres and what they tell us
about how we should read these works so
alienated labor or a strange labor
depending on how you wanna translate and
confront them dome is a manuscript from
1844 and it's one of these things that
later on Marx didn't publish in his
lifetime it's published within the
Soviet Union by some scholars in the
1920s and it's published among a bunch
of other
economic and political manuscripts and
these are sketches for the most part
that Marx was working on after he
finished his his graduate education and
as he is trying to figure out you know
where to go with things so he is using
some of the philosophical ideas that
he's come into contact with particularly
that of Hegelian philosophy turned in a
particular way he's turning his
attention to human economic life and to
what he can see going on in front of him
entity to history and to what we call
political economy and he's reflecting on
these now the notes are in some respects
fragmentary you know you notice that it
actually will say at the very end of
this piece the manuscript leaves off
here that's because that's where he quit
writing large parts of it are quite
worked out and developed but they're not
what we would expect to see in a
completely final form so you might say
that this is not necessarily a first
draft but you know a second draft a
third draft but it is a draft so you
want to keep that in mind as you're
approaching it there is some really
coherent thought there there's some
really central ideas in and talking
about the modes of alienation but we'll
get to that in a moment the other work
the Communist Manifesto it's kind of at
the other end of the scale as far as its
polished nature it is a finished work as
a matter of fact it's intended not just
as look you know sort of notes to a
scholar who's working on some ideas by
himself but for a completely public
audience when you write a manifesto what
you're doing is you're making public
your particular perspective and it's a
perspective in this case on human beings
on class struggle on economics on
politics on what should be done on who's
doing it the right way who's not doing
it the right way a lot of things are are
rolled into there so what they aim to do
in this is
make a sort of coherent exposition or
argument about what it is if the
Communists are all about so they're
presenting their core doctrines they're
presenting some of their key concepts
they're making some arguments and it's
for a group called the Communist League
now that one's co-written Marx
collaborates with a guy named Friedrich
Engels who he became friends with and
would collaborate on another lot of
other works with as well it's intended
to provide an articulation of their
basic ideas in a very clear form it's
not intended to provide all of the
supporting argumentation or exposition
it supposed to go boom boom boom boom
boom it and and you know take you
through the whole thing it's also so
intended to reach an audience that is
not just an educated elite but the
people at the other end of the scale the
proletariat who you know it's it's
supposed to be addressing you know when
when Marx says Marx and angles at the
end say you know the workers should
unite he's talking directly to the
workers so that's an important thing to
keep in mind and he's also addressing
other socialists and saying here's how
you guys are getting things wrong he's
also talked to the workers and saying
hey don't go after these guys they're
not they're not doing something that's
actually gonna make your lives better we
have the blueprint so now both of these
I should point out are actually early
works the alienated labor manuscript is
is from 1844 and the communist manifesto
is from 1848 so these are both from the
40s it's actually written before the
great uprisings of 1848 which forced
Marx and Engels to revise a little bit
of what they had to say about German or
true socialism in the third part now as
you're reading these for this class in
the form that I've presented them to you
you should read all of alienated labor
it's very short it's a pretty concise it
you know it's pretty clear in its
moving from point to point to point the
document that I'm providing you with for
the Communist Manifesto just read the
manifesto there this thing is often
packaged with a whole bunch of other
things like premises and letters and you
can even get it with like you know
Marx's cata kit or communist catechism
and you don't really need to read all of
that extra stuff in order to appreciate
what is going on in the manifesto the
manifesto is already dense enough it's
got three main parts each of which is
kind of its own separate treaties that
you want to work through so I would say
just focus on that portion so these are
the things to keep in mind as far as
genre as you're approaching these works
we've got sort of unfinished notes on
the one hand and we have a public
declaration of what this this movement
is all about on the other hand it's
interesting to think about historical
context for this work for these works
rather because not only was so much
going on but the 19th century if you
want to sum up philosophical ideas and
this is a little bit risky but if you
want to sum up in one word it would be
history philosophers were becoming very
conscious of what we call the historical
dimension of human existence the fact
that you know not only does development
take place but our consciousness changes
over time depending on the epoch that
we're in depending on how politics works
in that time depending on the economic
developments the activity the you know
the new things that are brought into
being so Marx and Engels are
deliberately focusing on the historical
development up until their own time that
you might say that they're interpreters
of their own present moment so that's
something you want to keep in mind as
far as historical context now let's
think about what was actually going on
at the time and what had preceded this
so as to
lead to the kind of things that Marx was
was writing so front and center we have
to talk about the development of modern
industrial society and when we're
thinking about that there is really
three main countries that were you might
say leading the charge on that and that
would be Britain the United States and
France Industrial Development was most
you know well worked out in those
countries and there's a whole story
there that could be told but that would
take up too much time about why why in
those areas Germany also had some
important industrial development going
on as well but as we're going to talk
about it hadn't progressed as far and
the class structure was somewhat
different in Germany than it was in
post-revolutionary France or in England
that was becoming dominated by by the
bourgeoisie or in America so you know
what happens in the development of
modern industrial society well you know
one of the key things that
differentiates industrial society from a
manufacturing society is that machines
are are taking over wider and wider
areas of production so human beings had
been harnessing the power of machine
since the ancient period you know we
have levers water wheels all sorts of
things like that but the Industrial Age
sees this very accelerated progress you
know creating things like like
steamboats creating things like much
better artillery but took a terrible
toll during this the civil war because
they they weren't quite adjusting for it
yet creating medicines creating dyes
creating you know industrial processes
in which parts of the assembly line are
no longer individual human beings but
individual human beings operating
machinery and sometimes machinery even
operating further machinery as we go on
into the late Industrial Age so
this is this transforms the world we
also see massive flooding of people from
the countryside's into the cities in
part because the cities were where most
of the the jobs were the manufacturing
and we see an incredible increase as
well in in poverty and human misery so
there's some really fascinating
developments taking place because all
this massive infrastructure and wealth
and you know things continually being
set in motion is happening but at the
same time it's becoming clear in part
because of better communications just
how miserable the lives of so many of
the people who are playing a role in
this and actually are and that's part of
what Marx is is responding to one of the
other things that's really important to
keep in mind is that there were some
really central political developments
the French Revolution which I've talked
about in several other videos made a
major impact in part by establishing the
bourgeoisie as the the ultimate ruling
party the people who were able to call
the shots and what we see happening in
the move to the modern age is the
decline of formerly privileged classes
like like kings or aristocracy or the
landed gentry or the clergy they end up
losing status and position not
necessarily in terms of rank but a lot
of their rank becomes ceremonial where
the real power lies is in the hands of
the people who are able to generate and
use and keep on developing further
wealth
they're the ones who assume higher and
higher status within society and they're
what we call the bourgeoisie in England
this
this class was rising and it led to some
tensions between aristocrats and you
know the new money as we call it in
America you know since it wasn't an
aristocracy it was it was a bourgeoisie
really running the show from from the
beginning and in France the French
Revolution swept away the previous class
structure and said that it was it you
know trying to liberate the people but
the people turned out to be primarily
the bourgeoisie the people who owned as
we say the means of production so you
see these classes vying for position and
the bourgeoisie is rising to the top in
Germany where Marx is coming from a
place that he's very interested in
what's happening instead is while the
bourgeoisie is rising the nobility is
still holding power and there's tensions
between them and the proletariat are you
know the workers are increasing but
they're in a different power structure
so these these developments mean an
awful lot intellectually Europe had
become one vast network there were
regional characteristics of course and
you can say that there were intellectual
back waters but communications were
vastly improving you know different
movements in philosophy are trickling
into politics into social life into
economics and and vice versa
philosophers are are taking account of
that the three you know dominant
countries as far as thinking the
intellectual life goes are that you know
triangle of England or the Great Britain
rather because it includes Scotland
where a lot was going on France and
Germany with you know the United States
way off you know across the Atlantic and
often importing ideas from from England
in France and then reworking them into
their own interesting forms in
philosophy the German idealists were you
might say the dominance philosophical
movement in the early 19th century but
like most dominant movements they end up
splitting into all different you know
separate camps and if you want a sort of
thumbnail sketch about what was going on
with with German idealism and and hay
galleon philosophy many of them are
going to turn away from idealism and
towards materialism like Marx himself
who claims to turn Hegel on his head
Hegel had thought that there was some
sort of rational process that is running
through history the process of human
development in which consciousness you
know moves from one step or one stage
one shape of consciousness to another
and it does so not by you know everybody
recognizing oh it's time to move the
rather by conflict by the conflict of
ideas born out sometimes even in violent
strife like the French Revolution and
there's a lot of experimentation that
goes on involved in this because we can
only see so far ahead so the French
revolutionaries for example thought that
they were instituting a realm of
absolute freedom against the unfreedom
of the previous monarchy and it's
corruption and it turns out that they
were instituting something that leads to
absolute error as well but that's an
important stepping stone on the stage
for development of humanity and one
thing that Hegel so this is you know the
the dialectical processes we as we call
it or as Hegel called that involves you
know moving from stage to stage to stage
through conflicts of ideas conflicts of
material forces that embody those ideas
against each other leading to greater
and greater synthesis as Hegel called
them now there were a number
of radical hag aliens marks among them
who took parts of Hegel's thought and
then said he was right about that but
he's totally wrong about this and now we
need to rethink this
so Hegel for example had thought that
religion was something very important in
the development of human beings that we
didn't want to get away from religion
but we wanted to sort of turn religion
into something like philosophy religion
was the penultimate stage in the
dialectical development or it's
absolutely knowing marks and feuerbach
before him say no religion is actually
something that's detrimental to human
beings for Bach would talk about it as
as a sign of our own alienation from
ourselves that we project these ideas
these religious ideas out there and we
give them power and we lose ourselves in
the process Marx will actually go so far
as to call religion the opiate of the
masses and by that he doesn't just mean
that they sit around smoking opium all
day feeling good and you know getting
getting high what he means is it's a
palliative for suffering that doesn't
actually address the causes of suffering
it comes out of human suffering as a
response it leaves the suffering in
place and so Marx is drawing upon you
know a notion philosophy that he's
getting from Hegel but he's radically
transforming it in the process he's
interested in thinking about the whole
of things the entire system and how all
of the parts fit together that's very
typically Hegelian he's also interested
in watching how these these processes
develop and trying to get a step ahead
and figure out which side of history we
need to be on there was also an
incredible emphasis at that time on what
we call political economy nowadays we
often call this policymaking or economic
theory or political theory and the idea
was that by by determinate by getting
the right
idea about how things like property or
the laws of supply and demand or how
markets work we could start to improve
the human condition and so people like
Adam Smith would be you know a central
person in in you know political economy
Smith is somebody who Marx actually
spent a lot of time studying and Marx is
is a student of political economy he's
very interested in it
but he thinks that it doesn't go deep
enough into figuring out what's really
going on so in terms of the themes of
our class it doesn't get to the
underlying realities that that prop up
political economy there were also some
other really interesting initiatives
going on you can see this reflected in
the communist manifesto it's you know
discussion of these even what we
nowadays call social theory or social
thought there was quite a bit of
reformist and utopian social thought
being proposed particularly in england
and particularly in France and Marx
spent a lot of time reading people like
charles fourier or SAS emo these are
people who are proposing new kinds of
ways of understanding society and along
with them ways to transform the human
being so that we would eliminate class
conflict and poverty and injustice and
inequalities marx actually came into
contact with some of the people who were
involved in certain of these movements
like the english Chartists now marx is
kind of an interesting character i want
to fit him into this history itself in
part because he is an international
agent of the revolution you might say he
starts out in germany and he's gonna
move to France to Paris and he's gonna
spend a little bit of time in Brussels
and then he's gonna be in in France and
and then in London so he's inhabiting
the key three centers of European
economics European politics
the European life as it's developing in
the mid 19th century to the late 19th
century Germany France England not to
say that other places didn't matter but
those were the places where the the
greatest initiative for changing things
was was occurring he wanted to it looks
like have an academic career at first
but he wasn't able to do so in part
because there was a sort of policy
against allowing people into academic
posts in in the state that he was in who
he had liberal or radical views and and
Marx did so a lot of the young Hegelians
or the radical hug aliens couldn't get
teaching posts because of that and so
Marx ends up going into journalism and
that's indeed how he made a good bit of
the money that he made during his
lifetime was by working as a journalist
for a lot of papers including one based
in in New York never made a ton of money
he actually lived in poverty a good part
of the time some of his children died
young because of that it's kind of a sad
story but he was committed to to living
among the working class and thinking out
the the responses to to what was going
on happened to the working class in
modern industrial society now one other
thing that I do have to mention that is
happening after these two texts are
written but is a very important part of
the story is the revolutions of 1848
1848 was a year in which these uprisings
are taking place and you know when we
talk about revolutions and we're
thinking about you know thinking back to
earlier ones like the American
Revolution or the French Revolution the
idea was that that people were you know
not just rising up in arms and saying
I've had it I can't take it anymore
that's a revolt a revolution attempts to
put a new state of affairs into place to
change the fabric of society so the
American Revolution tried to break
America's
Colony off from the British colonial
power and send America off on its own
course the French Revolution in many
respects even more radical trying to
tear out you know the the first two
estates clergy and nobility from the
French nation and elevate the Third
Estate the people into the positions of
power the revolutions that are taking
place in Germany primarily in 1848 but
but in a few other places as well are
going to aim at expanding human freedom
and there's a lot of different
initiatives going on Marx takes account
of that it's gonna have massive effects
you know people in Russia are going to
crack down after the revolutions
happening over in Europe sending people
like say Dostoevsky to to Siberia as a
result whole complicated story there but
the point is the sort of tensions the
sort of underlying conflicts that are
being discussed came to a critical
juncture point a crisis in 1848 and we
see further things going on and on after
that throughout the rest of the century
and Marx is is is at the heart of quite
a few of those the Communists play a
major role that he's they're not the
only people on the Left they're not the
only people working for revolutions
there are also anarchists and you know
various syndicalists but Marx's ideas
along with angles played a major role in
shaping where history was going to go
let's talk now about some of the key
themes that are going to keep on coming
up that you want to keep an eye out for
and try to at least you know have a good
solid understanding of by the time that
we're finished with this this section so
these are arranged and kind of a
constellation I'm not going to say that
one of them is necessarily more
important than the other because they're
all kind of connected with each other
the first of them
that I would bring up is this notion of
social classes so for Marx human beings
and their consciousness their way of
understanding themselves their way of
being in the world is determined in
large part by how they live and that's
determined by what social class they
belong to among the social classes we
should distinguish two of them as
particularly important to make sense of
one of them is what we call the
bourgeoisie these come from the original
townspeople the burghers in medieval
towns and eventually become the dominant
power the dominant social class within
modern industrial society taking the
other elite classes and either absorbing
them or pushing them away you know just
destroying the the means of their their
power and influence and eventually
dominating the world the other class
that's particularly important to think
about is what's called the proletariat
and the proletariat that's not a word
that's a you know original to Marx it
was used by the Romans to talk about
people who are so dirt poor that the
only thing that they had to contribute
to society was making more babies perlis
and Marx thinks that in modern
industrial society the vast majority of
people are forced into a position of
that sort of poverty where they don't
have opportunities they there's really
you know the whole system is rigged
against them and they they're unable to
accumulate wealth or to put it to work
and their cuz they're you know compelled
to have to work in order to live so
those are two important classes another
key idea is the conflict between social
classes as something that drives the
historical situation that we're in that
explains why things are the
that they are social classes are
involved in relations in which one
social class exploits another social
class and that leads to tensions and
conflict another key idea is that of
alienation or estrangement in German and
from them and this means they a state of
losing something of yourself of having
something of yourself taken away or
seeing it out there as something
standing against you and feeling that
not just thinking about that not just
realizing that's the situation you're in
but feeling it tear to your bones to in
your heart another key idea that is
closely connected with this is that of
human nature as fundamentally tied in
with creation and production with work
with labor along with this goes the key
idea or key theme of the centrality of
economics Marx believes that human
beings are fundamentally economic
creatures that is creatures involved in
production in exchange in consumption
and that's what really drives everything
he calls that the basis politics law
philosophy culture all these other
things are driven by what's happening in
people's economic lives and not the
other way around according to him so
another key idea Beck that goes along
with this would be the struggle between
what we call capital and labour and
capital is something that the the
bourgeoisie are able to accumulate and
use to consolidate and further their
position and it also it takes in labor
it's it's the the effect of labor that
other people have done and it's been
appropriated taken away from them
they've only been given wages in in
return and the capital is then
reinvested into the whole system to sort
of make the situation of the bourgeois
stronger and stronger making the
situation of the laborers or the
proletariat weaker and weaker another
key idea is that capitalism or you know
industrial society necessarily goes
through crises in which you know many
people are put out of work and there's
overproduction which leads to an
economic collapse misery on a grand
scale and that capitalism in its own you
know or on its own terms is unable to
actually prevent these crises from
happening this is something intrinsic to
the nature of the the capitalist economy
according to it - Marx another key idea
would be that of communism as a program
communism is the the proposal that Marx
and Engels have for how to make things
better for the working class instead of
just trying to reform things instead of
trying to improve their position by
raising wages the Communists say that
the proletariat has to take power
political power take over the state and
therefore take over the means of
production as well this leads us to
another key idea of the Communists one
of the ones that's probably the most
controversial which is that private
property as we know it as we understand
it in terms of bourgeois private
property needs to be abolished and
replaced by social property or
state-owned property there's a lot to be
said about this but we'll talk about
that more in some of the other videos
finally one of the other key themes is
that of what we call ideology and
ideology is a set of ideas so it's a
it's a connected set of ideas a loggia
logos of those
that represents the perspective or the
interests of a particular class at a
particular time but it's viewed by them
as being universal eternal good for all
human beings and so there's a kind of
masking that's going on of the real
situation etiology purports to tell us
the way things really are but it
actually conceals the way things truly
are and it ends up reflecting a kind of
false consciousness and it's very
difficult to combat but that's part of
what the Marxists are attempting to do
is to critique ideology so those are the
key themes to keep in mind as we go
through this work one last thing that I
would say particularly with this guy
there's a lot of historical baggage
associated with Marx and so if you
approach it saying I don't want to learn
anything cuz I know this guy's just a
dirty communist or a socialist and those
guys are all bad they want to take away
everything including my toothbrush
you're probably not going to get much
out of reading the work this is one of
those cases where you you probably want
to put aside whatever preconceived ideas
you have so you can read the text and
see what the text is actually saying and
then if you find yourself disagreeing
with the text afterwards after you fully
understood it that's perfectly fine